search and rescue efforts are indeed
getting underway today even as hurricane
Ian continues to pound the State of
Florida and make its way East take a
look at these pictures out of Naples
they show power lines sparking into
flames as they're down by Fierce winds
and rains overnight the result overall
in that state is more than 2 million
people waking up this morning without
power President Biden will be heading to
FEMA headquarters today to be briefed on
the impacts of Hurricane Ian we're
joined Now by FEMA administrator Deanne
Criswell from their headquarters in
Washington D.A Washington D.C uh
administrator Criswell uh since you're
going to be briefing the president later
today I am very curious what will you be
telling him about the effects of this
historic storm on the state of Florida
yeah good morning uh you know the
reports that we are getting uh so far
this morning are that there are
definitely catastrophic impacts people
that have been in the path of this storm
um are seen devastating effects to the
to them in their homes and so we are
very focused today our number one
priority is saving lives and we had put
together a large search and rescue
capability they've been out since four
o'clock this morning looking at areas
knowing that people may be trapped so we
can get in there and get as many people
to safety as we can
yeah you know administrator Chris well
that Florida has a very large elderly
population we hear reports of people
that can't get in touch with relatives
what's being done to assist them in
particular
yeah we know and we knew that there
would be power outages there would be
cell phone outages there would be other
types of outages and so people can call
if they can call and we're taking that
information and prioritizing but we
don't need to wait for that the teams
know what the areas are they're getting
direction from the local officials and
they're going to search all of the areas
that have had the hardest impact first
to make sure nobody's trapped and we can
get people to safety you say they should
call where should they be calling if
people are trapped and they have phone
service they should call 9-1-1 but if
people can't call know that we've got
people out there they're going to be
looking for them they know where to go
we are going to make sure we cover every
square inch of area that's been impacted
to make sure nobody needs assistance
administrator what is your message to
those who did not evacuate and those who
no longer can essentially just just
stuck where they are
emergency app
you should try to call 9-1-1 if you have
that ability if you don't I water is
still dangerous right people need to be
very careful there is a lot of water in
the area it has debris it has hazardous
chemicals there could be down power
lines people need to take extra care I
would say what we see often is that we
have an increase in the number of
indirect fatalities after a storm
because there's so many hazards that are
out there people need to stay vigilant
yeah is this storm more challenging than
others in the past I would imagine so we
keep hearing it being called The Storm
of the Century
let's bring their own unique challenges
absolutely but when you have a storm
like this that had category 4 Winds you
have large population areas but also
this intense storm surge and the
increased amount of rainfall and it
stayed right it moved very slowly it's
still in Florida we're starting and
still seeing impacts on the East Coast
this is going to leave a large path of
Destruction we put together the right
team to make sure we can go in there
right away we're already starting our
recovery planning process so we can get
these communities on the road to
recovery as soon as possible yeah
administrator the last time a storm like
this hit that part of the country was
100 years ago there were only hundreds
of thousands of people now there are
millions a lot of property damage are
you going to have the funding after a
storm like this to keep on doing what
you need to do to help people prepare
before during and then after storms do
you have the money and the resources
going forward
we absolutely have the money and the
resources to keep moving forward with
the the response phase that we have
right now as we get a better idea and
understanding of what the recovery costs
are going to be you know we'll continue
to work with Congress if there's
additional needs
female administrator Deanne Criswell
thank you so much
thank you for having me of course